нас журналістів не пускають в стіни
цього парламенту Ви що собі придумали
нам треба битися тут точно була образа
не треба тут розказувати хто справжня
опозиція а хто ні друзі Всіх вітаю це
парламент він уже порожній тому що слуги
і групи перепрацювалися сьогодні Ми
продовжуємо наше пленарне
[музика]
засідання я стара Шановні колеги зараз я
оголошує перерву у нашому пленарному
засіданні аж півтора дні на місяць у нас
пленарні зараз і за ці До речі півтора
дні депутати отримують більше 50 000
зарплати думаю що з цим щось треба
робити мені Мені здається Ні мені
здається Ні і європейська Солідарність
всі ці місяці воєнного стану вимагає аби
парламент повернувся до нормального
графіку роботи два пленарних тижні на
місяць робота в округах робота в
комітетах і аби парламент працював в
відкритому режимі щоби каналрада Ну не
вночі транслював у запису через 5пть
днів засіда і звичайно щоби журналісти
могли працювати в кулуарах секундочку
тут точно була образа До речі найбільш
бурхливим сьогодні було обговорення
призначення нового голови комітету
свободи слова це голосування за комітет
свободи слова за журналістику проти
політичної цензури за повернення правди
в цю залу і ми просимо підтримати дійсно
опозиційну фракцію не треба тут
розказувати хто справжня опозиція а хто
ні могила заснував Києво моля Академію
саме задля того щоб закінчивши її
йорчишин міг працювати хоч десь в якості
голови комітета зі свободи слова нагадаю
що в нинішньому парламенті в цьому
комітеті в якого забрали всі
повноваження в нас ні комітету ні
свободи слова Ну а попередній голова
комітету Шуфрич знаходиться в СІЗО там
знаходилися лише три депутати от Шуфрич
і двоє представників слуги народу хоч
завжди 30 років української незалежності
комітет свободи слова був дуже голосним
активним завжди ініціативним Саме цей
комітет свого часу і вводив квоти був і
автором закону про суспільне мовлення Ну
і робив багато важливих речей а зараз ні
свободи слова ні комітета владі
це потрібно європейська Солідарність як
опозиційна фракція подала постанову про
призначення нашого колеги Ростислава
Павленка головою комітету свободи слова
ми єдина фракція До речі як і піднімали
ці питання весь час в парламенті є
єдиний марафон який втратив свої
рейтинги і втратив довіру нас немає
медіаграмотності в нас насправді
відключені опозиційні телеканали
відключені без жодного пояснення без
жодних причин нас журналістів не
пускають в зону бойових дій і навіть в
стіни цього парламенту В нас мільйон
проблем обговорення проходило весело це
ж смішно правда відсутність свободи
слова і політична цензура давайте
продемонструємо ій планеті що ми
погоджуємось з тим що саме він
заслуговує на право працювати головою
комітета зі свободи слова він вдячний
нам Дякую класно Шановні колеги А я
викладав в києво-могилянській
академії Верховна Рада проголосувала за
призначення Ярослава Юрчишина головою
комітету свободи слова що ж тепер там
чотири представника один з них правда
знаходиться в СІЗО і не може навіть
онлайн включатись на засідання але
будемо сподіватися що тепер голос
помітить проблеми зі свободою слова з
марафоном з каналом рада з відсутністю
опозиції в Марафоні з чорними списками і
темниками як в найгірші часи медведчука
Ми сподіваємося що Ярослав Юрчишин
зверне на це
увагу а було прийнято дуже важливу заяву
звернення до всіх країн-членів ЄС для
підтримки позитивного рішення на
єврораді яка відбудеться вже 15 грудня
для для того щоби почалися офіційні
перемовини щодо вступу України до ЄС але
на жаль омріяним нами і вистрежено
нашими воїним Рішення ще далеко не в
кишені за
нього ці пть днів що залишилось нам
треба не просто боротися а битися і це
завдання для
дипломатів це завдання для парламентарів
це завдання для активістів європейська
Солідарність ініціювала Таку заяву
відкрила її для підписання всім
депутатським групам і фракціям закликали
колег доєднатися до цієї важливої
постанови але потім ми її всеідо нам там
заблокували на певний час і з'явилася
раніше інша постанова з керівництва
серед авторів керівництва парламенту
лідери опзж теж Ну це такі у нас
євроатлантисти тепер відомі не було там
тільки європейської солідарності нас не
запросили Я особисто хочу звернутися до
ліде
країн Не
дивлячись на інколи справедливі оцінки і
щодо права позиції свободи слова
демократії корупції це подарунок не
владі чи опозиції це рішення
багатостраждальному українському народу
який 10 років проходить можливо
найважчий шлях до членства в
Європейському Союзі і НАТО ми тут як
державники завжди діємо для того щоб
продемонструвати гідність в ключовому
питанні так само парламент проголосував
закон про криміналізацію контрабанди
скандальний закон проти якого виступали
бізнес-асоціації як українські так і
європейські ви пішли знову через інший
шлях абсолютно неприйнятний для
демократичної країни і уявляєте собі до
кінця цього року ця стаття 2011
знаходиться в підслідності СБУ СБУ
ніякої довіри від бізнесу немає бізнес
весь час жаліється Надії СБУ але з 1
січня 24го року ця стаття в підслідності
беб Ви що собі придумали беб який ви
кожного дня згадуєте як самий
неефективний правоохоронний орган внесли
певні зміни після критики бізнесу Ну але
все одно цей законопроект звичайно б'є
по експортеру імпортеру і він дуже
серйозно б'є по українсько бізнесу тут
ми утрималися але голосами слух І груп
цей законопроект
прийнято за 248 рішення прийнято Мені
дуже сумно спостерігати за діями цієї
Верховної Ради Я впевнена що згодом ми
будемо переглядати повністю кримінальну
відповідальність по товарній контрабанді
Ну І от до повноважень голови Верховної
Ради згідно Конституції звичайно не
належить повноваження знаєте там галочки
ставити навколо відряджень депутатів і в
екселівську таблицю це вносити якось
слідкувати за опозицією його завдання -
це організувати нормальну роботу
парламенту бачимо з цим біда може він
тільки зібрати депутатів на півтора
пленарних дні і навіть не сьогодні
президія знову не зачитала запити
депутатські тому що ми знаємо що
накопичилося достатньо багато Запитів це
важливий так само інструмент нашого з
вами впливу парламентського контролю і
це ми просимо сьогодні їх оголосити Ну
от серед Запитів європейської
солідарності які ми підготували зокрема
є і запит щодо візиту до Сполучених
Штатів трьох десятків слух і їх
підголосків за бюджетні кошти вони там
тиждень десь були в Штатах різних
привезли звідти два прапори з підписами
діаспори ми написали так Скільки ж це
обійшлося державному бюджету і хто
формував на банковій цю делегацію тому
що туди увійшли дійсно тільки слуги Ну і
там пару людей підголосків ще з однієї
фракції сказати так щоб відверто Я думаю
ніхто не знає ми будемо вимагати
насправді і повернення години запитань
до уряду тому що це ненормально що ложа
уряду Подивіться Да От вона зараз
порожня але не тільки зараз а в цілому
весь цей час ми бачили прем'єр-міністра
один раз він навіть не прийшов на
представлення бюджету а в парламентсько
президентській Республіці очевидно що
уряд має бути підзвітним парламентом де
година запитань до уряду де Я питаю за
600 днів один раз ми мали тут пана
шмигаля Да ми забули як він виглядає
плутаємо його з шарлям мішелем друзі
підписуйтеся на наш YouTube канал Ми
продовжимо інформувати вас про роботу
парламенту і робимо це безкоштовно на
відміну від каналу рада за який 170 млн
грвень іде от з бюджету Верховної Ради
але там немає парламенту І до речі за
отаке безчинство голосували слуги і на
жаль частина голосу підписуйтеся лайк те
коментуйте все буде Україна друзі